[ __ ] is that  that was for Mad Max a video game was a  little real call exactly they gave us a  little picture of it we built the real  car man  so tell me well to hell you what are  these truck tires with yeah so we built  it on a ford ranger chassis and then  this is a maverick body on top of it and  then of course we cut the hood and  brought the motor out we had to kind of  give it the look but not really build it  out of metal so it kind of shows the  variety of like we can actually build  this it looks like metal but it's  actually fiberglass and then this is all  metal work okay so you don't have to  take this to an interior shot no to a  sound man no sir you don't have even  taken no way to get the car walk no way  everything right here everything oh you  need a gas pump I know that's that's  next right  we need a little gas station in the back